مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره معي انا عبيده
نفاق
[موسيقى]
مبارح بدات تظهر التقارير والانباء عن قرب
انتقال كريم بنزيما الى اتحاد جده السعودي
في انباء عن تقديم عرض كبير بالبعد يقول
انه قيمته 400 مليون اربعه يقول انه قيمته
215 مليون يعني في تضارب بالانباء حول
الرقم وفي حتى لحد الان لا يوجد اي مصدر
رسمي ليؤكد انه اصلا في عرض تقدم ولكن
صحفي المختص بسوق الانتقالات فابريزي
رومانو اكد انه في عرض فعلا تقدم من جانب
نادي الاتحاد السعودي نظام كريم بنزيما
قبل مباراه اشبيليه او ريال مدريد يوم
الجمعه وانه اللاعب خبر اداره ريال مدريد
انه راح يفكر بالموضوع ابتداء من يوم
الثلاثاء الماضي ومن المتوقع انه على مدار
الايام القليله المقبله اللاعب يقرر مصيره
اما الانتقال الى السعوديه او تجديد عقده
مع ريال مدريد لموسم اخر الكل بيعرف انه
عقد بنزيما ينتهي مع الفريق الملكي هذا
الموسم بنهايه يعني على الصيف خلص انتهى
عقد بنزيما مع ريال مدريد وبالتالي هو
سيكون قادرا على الانتقال بصفقه انتقال حر
لاي نادي اخر ان كان في اوروبا ولا برا
اوروبا وريال مدريد يسعى لتجديد عقد
اللاعب ولكن بعض العرض السعودي على ما
يبدو حسب التقارير بنزيما بدا يفكر بموضوع
الانتقال الى السعوديه بصرف النظر هل هذه
التقارير الصحيحه ولا لا وهل قدم الاتحاد
عرضا لبنزيما ولا لا خلينا نشوف هل هو
الوقت المناسب اصلا لانتقال بنزيما الى
السعوديه بنزيما صار عمره 35 سنه تقريبا
ومسيره الكرويه من لما بتطلع عليها ابتداء
بليون وانتهاء ريال مدريد 2023 بتشوف انه
بدات
بتصاعد وبعديها لما انتقل الى ريال مدريد
بال 2009 انحدرت بشكل كبير لحتى اجى زيدان
بال 2016 وصار يرتفع او صار يرتفع الخط
البياني لهاي المسيره بشكل تدريجي لوصل
للقمه بموسم
2021-2022 بعد 2021-2022
صار بنزيما يسال نفسه هل ممكن ان يقدم شيء
جديد لريال مدريد هل في يعني شيء ما قدمته
الموسم الماضي دوري الابطال جبناه الدوري
الاسباني جبناه جاب الكره الذهبيه مع
فرنسا خلص ما في امل انه يحقق اي شيء مع
المنتخب وبالتالي ما عاد عنده حافز انه
يضل باوروبا لحتى ينضم للمنتخب الفرنسي
ومع ريال مدريد هو حقق كل شيء فعليا يعني
ما عاد عنده شيء ما عاد عنده حافز
وبالتالي بلاش يفكر بالخطوه اللاحقه او
الخطوه الاخرى اللي راح تيجي ليش ممكن
يكون الانتقال الى السعوديه هو الخيار
ربما الافضل بالوقت الراهن بالنسبه لكريم
بنزيما وليش ممكن يكون لا في خيارات افضل
منه هو الخيار الافضل لانه بنزيما يعني
بالوقت الحالي 35 سنه متل ما حكينا اوروبا
ختمها وبالتالي حلو انه يروح يخوض تجربه
جديده بالسعوديه يكون بالدوري اللي فيه
كريستيانو رونالدو مره اخرى يكون النجم
الاول والاحد مع رونالدو طبعا في هذا
الدوري ويكون بنفس الوقت مستفيد ماديا
يعني خلينا نحكي بصراحه انه في فائده
ماديه انتقل على السعوديه وراح يكون سفير
السعوديه ايضا لكاس العالم 2030 ونحن
بنعرف كلياتنا انه لعيبه الكبار لما
يروحوا على السعوديه ولما يروحوا على
الدوري السعودي بكون في امتيازات كبيره
جدا وبيحكوا بحياه جميله جدا وبتعاملوا
معامله خاصه وبالتالي بنزيما بحاجه هذا
التقدير بعد موسم يعني نزل في مستواه كثير
مع ريال مدريد واتعرض لكثير انتقادات
السبب اللي ما بيخليه ربما يروح على
السعوديه اول شيء انه بنزيما بعده قادر
يعطي على الاقل موسمين او ثلاثه باوروبا
يعني بنزيما صحيح مستواه نزل هذا الموسم
بسبب بعض الاصابات ولكن بنزيما يبقى
بنزيما وبنزيما عنده الجوده وعنده
الكواليتي وكان ظاهر بكثير مباريات لا بل
انه كان عم ينافس على لقب هداف الدوري
الاسباني وبالتالي ما فينا نحكي انه مسيره
بنزيما مثلا انتهت مع كره القدم الاوروبيه
او انه ما عاد قادر انه مثلا يلعب موسمين
او ثلاث مواسم بالتوب ليفل باوروبا هو
قادر ولكن اذا صحت الانباء حول العرض
السعودي المقدم وخلينا نقول على اقل تقدير
هو 100 مليون يورو فهذا العرض راح يكون
اضعاف المبلغ اللي راح يتلقاه من ريال
مدريد واعتقد انه بحال اختار السعوديه
فهذا راح يكون الحافز الرئيسي بالمقابل
انتقال بنزيما الاتحاد جده راح يكون نقل
نوعيه لهذا الفريق بطل الدوري اللي عنده
منظومه دفاعيه قويه جدا اللي رايح ينافس
على دوري ابطال اسيا الموسم الجاي اتحاد
جده بحاجه لخطوه لجذب الانظار العالميه
نحو النصر عمل مع كريستيانو رونالدو ومثل
ما الهلال عم يحاول يعمل مع ميسي وطبعا ما
راح نعدل فوائد اللي راح يجيبها بنزيما
معه على الكره السعوديه وعلى اتحاد جده هل
سينتقل بنزيما ولا لا هذا امر لحد الان
بحكم الغيب وبعده اللاعب على حسب التقارير
عم يتناقش مع عائلته ليقرر شو راح يعمل
ولكن بالتاكيد انه ارتباط اسم بنزيما
بالكره السعوديه بحد ذاته هو شيء يدل على
انه الدوري السعودي اصبح يستقطب اكبر
النجوم حول العالم هذا كان كل شيء بحلقه
لون بعض الصافره حتى نلتقي الاسبوع المقبل
بكونوا بالف خير